hi guys my name is Portia and I'm a
makeup artist and it influencer and
today I'm gonna be doing a 90s
supermodel look for you guys so if you
want to see how I create this look keep
on watching to create this look I'm
going to be using products or from
Smashbox and the first step is priming
so the first product I'm going to be
using is the primer Iser it's really
cooling down my face actually minimizes
so next I'm going to be using the iconic
primer and this has a great mattifying
effect I have quite early skin so this
is working wonders right now I'm going
to be using the eye primer which is
going to go under my eyes I just put
some on the eyelid as well because it
feels so great so now I'm going to apply
the foundation it's a 15 hour where
foundation it's oil free and it has an
amazing matted effect that goes
obviously with this look that I'm doing
for you today it doesn't settle into any
pores or lines and it's just basically
amazing so I'm using the blurring
foundation brush but you can always use
your fingertips as well if you prefer so
next I'm going to fill in my brows using
a tech matte pencil feathery strokes
just to kind of fill in the sparse areas
and then use the comb on the other end
to just brush that color into my brows
so it looks super natural so next I'm
going to be putting on some brown
eyeshadow from the pet or metal palette
and I'm going to be blending this in
with the blending shadow bra
so I'm using a mixture of a coffee
blossom and the nude rose so I really
like the way it starts off like in a
really nice coffee color and then it
just becomes just like a warmer brown so
next I'm going to be using eyeliner in
bare which is going to make my eye
basically pop and look bigger
I'm now going to use the super thumb
mascara and I'm going to go from the
root to the tip and just fan it out all
along my lash line I think it would be
quite nice if I just added a little bit
of this brown under my lash line I think
you look really good and then I'm gonna
add the mascara for the bottom lash okay
so now I've done the eyes I'm gonna be
doing some contouring so now I'm going
to be using the Cali contour palette
with the blush brush this brush is great
because it's angled so it really helps
you go along the shape of your face I'm
just gonna add a little bit of blush
now I'm going to use a little bit of
highlighter is called Hollywood and
highlight and it's got a little sponge
on it as well so it's going to help me
to really buff it in so next we're doing
lips and I'm going to start with a lip
liner this one is actually called
audition it's time to put on your
lipstick and this one in particular is
called monogamous so now I finished the
complete look I'm just going to be
setting it now so I'm going to use the
iconic primer my favorite just to take
off any oil that I can see that's kind
of developed throughout putting on the
makeup okay and now I'm going to be
using the set spray
I hope you enjoyed watching me create
this autumn winter look if you really
liked this video please comment and
share and if you want to see more videos
like this please head over to Glamour
UK's achieve
[Music]